hey everyone it's Mike from overflows
here and welcome back to my channel I'm
glad you could join me for today's video
where I'll be talking about Delta
footprint charts and again before we
jump in if you haven't already please be
sure to subscribe to the channel and
click the notification Bell so you don't
miss any new uploads that I do
um and if you find today's video helpful
be sure to hit the like button and leave
a comment
um you know sharing your biggest
takeaway and potentially some
suggestions for future videos because
today's video is again based off of a
user comment uh
that came from uh was again I'm gonna
butcher your name I'm sorry uh
sheikharc hindria
um it says I saw your various videos all
are great I just want to know if I can
make another video about Delta footprint
charts and how we can trade
via them except using them to see
absorption zones okay so you know the
regular volume of footprint chart or you
know the basically the basic footprint
chart that most of us are familiar with
looking at is the
bid ask footprint you know the volume
that's traded on the bid the volume
that's traded on the offer
and a lot of the Overflow or software
out there has the ability to pull up a
Delta footprint okay and
just really quick what the Delta
footprint is it's a horizontal Delta
okay what that means is it's Delta at
price so for example down here in this
bar at 44 90 and a quarter you see 75
traded on the bid
25 traded on the offer it will take the
Delta for this price just as one tick
above at 44.90 spot 50. it's 137 on the
bid and 71 on the offer it's going to
take the difference between the bid
volume and the offer volume at Price not
in the two-way auction right because
when we look at a regular footprint
right a regular bid ask footprint we
tend to compare prices diagonally in the
two-way auction however a Delta
footprint will just give you the Delta
at that price not in the two-way auction
some software has the ability to give it
to you in the two-way auction but the
most commonly used Delta footprint is
horizontal which is Delta at price and
on my order flows Trader software
if you could scroll down to ladder
content right you'll see cell text and
the default to set the bid ask you have
your choice of Delta which we'll look at
today volume and diagonal Delta people
ask you know which is better the Delta
at Price or diagonal Delta me personally
I I'm I'm fine with just normal Delta at
price and so you're just gonna
choose Delta and click apply then click
ok ok now you're going to see at each
price level if the Delta was positive or
negative on the order flows Trader it
will if it was negative Delta which
means it was there's more aggressive
selling into passive buying
it's going to show us negative Delta if
there was more aggressive buying
that it's going to show
positive Delta it's going to be on the
right side so you see anytime I see
minus 77 minus 34 minus 89 minus 66
minus 50. that negative numbers are
going to be on the left hand side which
is the mid side the positive number is
always going to be on the right hand
side the offer side
and how you can use this is basically
it's telling you that more volume traded
on the bid
if it's negative than on the offer if
it's positive more volume traded on the
offer
than on the bid side that's why there's
no volume on the bid side when there's
volume on the offer side just as there's
no volume on the offer side when there's
volume on the bid side okay so what does
all this mean now remember this is Delta
it's not the actual volume it's the
difference between the volume traded on
the bid and the volume traded on the
offer at a price and there are certain
patterns that I like to look for because
when I see a market right you can see
bars is going to have at Price levels
it's going to have positive Deltas it's
going to have negative Deltas
um you know at different levels right we
don't know until the actual trading is
done like for example this bar we don't
know that the bottom part of this bar is
going to be all negative Delta right
which when I see that in a green candle
is assigned to me of you know a form of
absorption right in that bar doesn't
necessarily mean it's absorption for the
whole entire day but in this bar the way
this bar developed you know it opened up
here tried selling off
but there were strong passive buyers to
absorb that selling here here here here
here
the market rallied back you got the
aggressive buying coming in here uh 107
68 80 32 okay now
this is where it gets a little bit
interesting okay because like I said you
know every bar is going to have some
sort of volume either on the bid or on
the offer and honestly a lot of times
it doesn't mean anything right we all
like to try and read things into the
market in my opinion and majority of the
time it doesn't mean anything where I
like to use
Delta Footprints is what I'm analyzing
turning points in the market okay and
you know for example right obviously we
hit the high of the day right up here we
sold off down here and then we started
reversing in this bar right we got that
long Wick and in that Wick
I see aggressive selling into passive
bids here right passive bids are people
that are working bids the aggressive
selling aggressive selling aggressive
selling aggressive selling how do I know
it's aggressive selling well it's
negative Delta right it got through this
price level this price level this price
level this price level and stopped down
here then It reversed and I see the
aggressive buying coming in how do I
know that's aggressive buying well one
is traded on the offer right it's the
aggressive buyers are buying from the
passive Sellers and price is moving
higher this is you know like a reversal
bar to me okay when I got that strong
selling going down into a low area
again this is a swing low right we just
sold off and then followed up with
aggressive buying coming up here I'd be
looking for this Market to pop up
okay now bars where it's kind of mixed
you know like this bar right up here
right off the high not the bar on the
high but the bar right after
positive Delta negative negative
positive negative positive negative
that's nothing like that doesn't mean
anything to me at least maybe somebody's
got a way of analyzing it but you know
I've looked at these bars I spent a lot
of time with them
and to me that's that just normal
trading taking place like I said where
I'm looking for
[Music]
um
the Deltas to come in play you know is a
sign of absorption or potentially trap
Traders
is at swing highs or swing lows or
basically you know after a move has been
made or there's going to be other times
like here okay so look at this we
rallied up made the high started going
sideways tried to break down a little
bit right and at this point you know
this is sort of this was your sort of
Swing Low here from the time we had hit
that high then we get this strong we get
this little push down with strong volume
here now again this is Delta at Price
minus 507 on the bid I don't I'm not
looking I'm not saying this 507 was the
amount of contracts that's the
difference between the volume that
traded on the bid here at 44.89 and a
half versus the volume traded on the
offer at 89 and a half and it was minus
507 so it's quite strong right price got
through there got through there got
through there and then reversed back up
so when I see it sort of poke below a
recent low and I just see some strong
aggressive selling coming in here I know
it's met with absorption I know that
there was passive buyers here basically
to absorb whatever is taking place if
this Market went down a little further I
might see you know some more signs you
know the negative Delta at Price here
absorbing it
right so when I see it sort of poke down
below and then come back up into that
range
I'm already thinking that you know what
there's potentially some
um absorption taking place down here
right Market sort of go sideways and
then pops back up now
you know sort of the you know one of the
patterns I introduced several years ago
which has been
um
used and abused by other Traders
stealing it as their own I call it Delta
tail okay and basically what that is
it's a red candle down with all negative
Deltas but with a positive Delta on the
top that's sort of your tail right this
is what it looks like on a bearish bar
if I could find a bullish bar here you
know there's another bearish bar right
here
um
see if I can find a bullish one really
quick this would be a bullish one right
negative Delta on the bottom of the
green candle all positive Delta because
what it's telling you is you know the
bar open push a little bit lower ran
into some absorption and then all
aggressive buying taking place right and
the opposite is true up here right bar
opened up met some passive
sellers up here and then all aggressive
selling coming in down here
okay now look at this okay so we had
this nice move up
up up you get up here at the high of the
day
and it's all
positive Delta
so I know that up here there was
probably some decent liquidity coming up
in here right now as you're going up
when people say why is this bar so
important why is it not this one here or
this one well I know
you know as you're going up into a high
I'm not going to run into liquidity I
mean I'm going to be running into offers
at the highs of the day okay and again
so I'm not surprised to see it ball you
know positive Delta positive Delta
positive Delta then even up here
positive positive positive but then when
I get up here I'm still got that I still
got those resting offers in the market
that are getting taken out
but then what happens is
they're left up there right these four
price levels with positive Delta then
it's all negative Delta here so I know
that we had that aggressive buying
coming in here
and then there's aggressive selling
coming in now how is that different than
a bar like this well this is a green
candle price is still going up the move
has not move up has not ended
right even though this bar looks kind of
similar to this bar in the sense that
you get positive Delta on the upper
right hand side right and you got
negative Delta on the bottom left hand
side but the price action is telling you
this Market is still moving higher what
I want to see is the markets stop moving
then the aggressive selling coming in
because at this bar you know it's sort
of forming differently this bar opened
up traded down and then the aggressive
buying came in this bar opened up traded
up ran into strong passive Sellers and
then the aggressive selling came in and
we closed down
okay now
um
some Traders I've identified a bar like
this where it's just all negative Delta
or you know if it was a green Barbie all
positive Delta as being a bearish sign
yeah I guess so I mean it's all
aggressive selling in that single bar I
forgot what the word is that they used
for Delta Tower or something like that
okay I see a lot of these though at ends
of moves or at lows of the day you know
this one's coming in up here near the
high of the day I might put a little bit
more uh strength into it but again I've
got my
um Delta tail right here anyway
um you know before this came in
but again you know when you see a big
bar like this where it's all aggressive
selling
sometimes it's pretty obvious but uh
okay I mean it is what it is right I
mean sometimes you know some people love
this would love a bar like this
some people would love a bar like this
some people will love a bar like this
[Music]
um
you know it's
really something again if you're looking
at Delta at price
for me I think it's most
best utilized you know around the edges
right around highs or lows or swing
highs or swing lows and if I'm looking
at a move okay I can move higher
um taking out new highs you know today
we got a big
this is what this is a eight range chart
uh we got where's the cash open
somewhere in here 837 right we started
going up
taking out these highs
what I like to see I don't see it
developing here in the e-minis today
but what I would like to see right when
we're going up I like to also see not
just the offers being taken out right
that's what you want to see right you're
going higher higher higher what I would
like to also see is bids coming in
you know in the bar as well strong
support of buying I don't see it right
here but let me see as we get a little
bit higher here like right here this
minus 349 you know is is nice I would
prefer it came in here like this minus
239 but again we got a strong offer here
minus uh 1 000 or sorry positive one
thousand in Delta but as we come up here
make a new high
370 negative Delta so I know again this
is not volume this is the difference
between the volume that was trading on
the bid the volume of Australian Opera I
know 370 is pretty strong I mean granted
we did have you know a thousand here 500
here but anything above 250 is an eight
range chart
um in my opinion is generally pretty
strong because I don't see a lot right
again I'm just eyeballing it really
quick I see a lot of stuff in the night
in you know between 50 to 150. so 370
that's a strong bid coming in that's
what you want to see when a market is
going up just as here when a market is
starting to go down right it's dropping
and I see a strong offer coming in 422
to me that's strong
right on a market that's falling so I
know that there's Supply coming into the
market how can I tell is because I see
the strong Delta coming in here at 44.76
and a quarter this 422 contracts
okay so again you know when you're
dealing with volumes you know you want
to be paying attention to what the
volume is that's you know trading
basically
um because that's going to give you sort
of insights into you know what's taking
place in the market
um and again you know as this Market is
going up right you see it's going up
it's got a decent bid well not a decent
bid but you know a decent volume minus
147 it's sort of on the higher end
um again I'd like something above 200
250 but again volume is relative
okay and you can see as it's going up
here see some decent bids coming in here
in the sense of Delta 3 minus 320 minus
304 minus 300 right at the highs of the
day here right that's what this line is
right and just as you going up right you
want to see those strong bids coming
into the market
right not just offers being lifted I
mean that's just one part of the
equation it's nice to see the offers
being lifted that's what you need
for the market to go higher but to stop
the market from dropping you're going to
need decent bids so if you're seeing
decent bids coming in in terms of Deltas
at Price you know basically meaning you
have negative Delta you know some
basically some supportive bids in the
market
on the way up that's a you know to me
that that's like the extra bonus the
cherry on top of of what you're looking
for
okay so I hope you guys appreciate this
video and got something out of it you
know a Delta
at price chart is something that's uh
extremely useful so if you're not using
it
um you know take a look at it watch it
see if you could use it in your trading
and I'll see you guys on the next video
bye-bye